[Music]
you know i live for a beauty tip so
here's one for you hopefully you'll love
hey drew it's chris appleton and today
i'm going to show you how to create a
messy bun in a few simple steps all
you're going to need is a hairbrush
a couple of pins and i love to use the
color wow style and storage texturizing
spray when you're creating a messy bun
the key is to keep a lot of texture in
the hair it increases the diameter of
the hair and gives you a lot of volume
then what you want to do is work the
hair up now what i like to do is just
keep it a couple of pieces down at the
front and then using my fingers just
pull the hair up into a high ponytail
now the key for you guys creating this
at home is to follow your cheekbone
that's the perfect place for you to land
your ponytail then we're going to take
our elastic
and tie the hair
up high now remember when you're doing
this you want to make sure you almost
got a little bit higher than what you
want just because naturally when you're
tying your hair high it always tends to
fall a little bit lower i like to then
just take my brush and all we're going
to do
is take the bun and just tease it a
little bit so we have a little bit more
volume i have a couple of pins all you
want to do is twist the hair and wrap it
around
in a circular motion taking the very
ends and just tucking them underneath
then what i like to do once you get the
position right is just pin it in place
or like i say you need just a couple of
pins so we'll put
one on this side
one on this side and that should be held
in place a little bit closer you can see
there's nice texture in there it's not
too neat so don't start getting anything
that's too perfect this is your pin you
want to use i'm just taking a large pin
and just anchoring it right at the base
of the bun
just on both sides here at this point
all you want to do is just go in and
refine the edges i like to use my
fingers if there's any like real lumps
and bumps i'll just take my pin and just
pin it into place just so you can kind
of really tidy up the edges and then see
any little fly away hairs like this i
like to then use the star on steroids
texturizing spray just to help give me a
bit more volume and hold i don't think
you need hairspray on this because it
should be light and airy and have that
really voluminous finish
i can't wait to try that
[Music]
you